okay when I started preparing this story
I thought that the big news that I would
be reporting to you would be plainly
that Roger stone has been arrested and
charged with multiple crimes right it's
another Trump insider who has fallen
getting closer and closer to Donald
Trump himself and that is a huge story
this pre-dawn FBI raid being used
because Robert Muller understandably was
worried that Roger stone would try to
destroy evidence if given the
opportunity but the even bigger story is
that now Roger stone is no longer ruling
out cooperating with Robert Muller this
is the guy stone who was never gonna
flip the guy that Trump was holding up
as a hero for not cooperating he might
be cooperating check out my interview by
the way with Roger stone which we
replumb republished to the YouTube
channel where of course he denies all
wrongdoing of all kinds no one's going
to get him for anything because he just
did nothing wrong ever obviously that
doesn't appear to have been the case
although he is still obviously innocent
until proven guilty the details here are
that he is being charged for lying to
the House Intelligence Committee about
interactions with WikiLeaks in the 2016
campaign obstruction witness tampering
this series of charges is huge in a few
different ways number one it's more
connections to Russia and that's huge
and stone is right in there with it here
is stone by the way leaving the
courthouse on the day of his arrest to
chance of lock him up from the crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
what a show I mean just absolutely
stunning so more connections to Russia
more chance to lock him up but the real
question now that we know more about how
yeah WikiLeaks was involved in helping
Trump defeat Hillary and yeah stone was
in talks with WikiLeaks and yes Donald
Trump's public statements about document
dumps seemed to correlate really closely
with WikiLeaks suspiciously so the
question now is was Trump really totally
in the dark about the stone connections
to WikiLeaks and therefore to Russia as
I've said before it's very hard to
believe that Trump was in the dark about
the Trump Tower meeting with a Russian
lawyer and it's just as difficult to
believe that he didn't know that
WikiLeaks was helping his campaign so
all of this is huge but then remember
this tweet from last month Donald Trump
tweeting quoting Roger stone I will
never testify against Trump this
statement was recently made by Roger
stone essentially stating that he will
not be forced by a rogue and
out-of-control prosecutor to make up
lies and stories about President Trump
nice to know that some people still have
guts well not so fast because we now
have Roger stone telling George
Stephanopoulos on ABC that he is no
longer ruling out cooperating with
Robert Muller take a look at this you
say you won't bear false witness against
President Trump are you prepared to tell
the truth about your dealings with him
to the special counsel your truth about
your dealings with the campaign any
chance you'll cooperate with special
counsel Robert Muller if he asks you
know that's a question I would have to
do I'd have to determine after my
attorneys have some discussion if
there's wrongdoing by other people in
the campaign that I'd know about which I
know of none but if there is I would
certainly testify honestly I'd also
testify honestly about any other matter
including any communications with the
president it's true that we spoke on the
phone but those communications are
political in nature they're benign and
there's there isn't certainly no
conspiracy with Russia presidents right
there is no Russia and he's never
suggested to you in any way
perform that you that he might offer you
a pardon absolutely positively not
I have never discussed a pardon the only
person that I had advocated a pardon for
as we've discussed previously is a
posthumous pardon for marcus garvey yeah
so lots of caveats lots of ifs and
conditionals but that is not a no I will
not cooperate and that's already a major
change from what Donald Trump at least
seemed to believe about Roger stone as
recently as six weeks ago so there's a
few things here ignore the fact that
Roger stone spent 12 minutes professing
his innocence here Trump tweeted now to
distance himself from Roger stone over
the weekend Roger stone didn't even work
for me anywhere near the election an
election of course with a capital e but
that's neither here nor there so stone
understands that he's in trouble because
he's now no longer ruling out
cooperating with Robert Muller of course
to tell the truth if he knew of anything
which he doesn't know about he probably
sees that Trump is bailing on him going
from touting him as a hero from not
cooperating just six weeks ago to saying
Roger stone Roger stone who he didn't
even work for me anywhere near this
campaign so read between the lines and
Roger stone went from it's all a
witch-hunt to I'd cooperate if my
lawyers thought that it was a good idea
in the matter of effectively what is
just ours stunning we are going to
follow it and of course it could be a
while until we actually see what sort of
consequences they're going to be for
Roger stone here because these things
don't always take place as quickly as we
might like to see if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
purse
productivity and I'm not even really
scratching the surface I recently took a
great class on introductory watercolour
painting I'm still not good but I am
learning and you can access the entire
library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video